[Music]
this morning on the dish your mother
always said eat your vegetables
for chef steven satterfield that saying
has become his life's work
a pioneer in farm to table dining his
seasonal southern cooking at his
restaurant miller union in atlanta
makes produce not protein the star and
by utilizing all parts of a plant
from root to leaf he's kept customers
and critics
coming back for years this is the
cucumbers over here
yeah these are the cucumbers in order to
understand chef steven satterfield
there's a little bit of a bitterness to
it but it's nice it's refreshing
you have to start at the root literally
[Laughter]
that's why we met him at a small organic
farm
30 minutes from downtown atlanta is that
the first onion you've harvested
yeah very first snapfinger farm is one
of the dozens that supply his restaurant
miller union with fresh produce every
day
because we serve you know hundreds of
people
a week we really have to buy from a lot
of farms and diversify
so and that way we can support more
farmers a native georgian satterfield
has revolutionized farm to table dining
and in turn the way people think about
southern cooking
i think southern food is interesting
because
it's very complex and it's deeply rich
in history
from many sides you can honor it
and and cook traditionally or you can
take that as a starting point
and put your own spin on it he's been
putting a spin on it
since 2009 when he stormed onto the
national culinary scene
12 years later and after countless
awards including a james beard in 2017.
satterfield is still very much in season
you're still here and you're still at
the top of your game
it's really rewarding to be recognized
for all the hard work
that we do we are on people's bucket
list and
i'm deeply grateful for that because
it's showing
the good work of the farmers on the
plate and it's showing people
what hospitality is through the years he
has stayed true to his mission
providing simple seasonal produce driven
food
that highlights local ingredients to me
vegetables
are just as important as meat
they're just as important if not more
important
and it's dynamic you know what i mean
like you can always get that great
pasture-raised chicken or that grass-fed
beef that we
love to serve too and that's kind of
year-round but it's those seasonal pops
that really just get me going
his menu also got us going a field pm
peanut salad with fresh lemon ricotta
grilled cabbage with peaches pecans and
goat cheese roasted beets with
blueberries pistachios and feta
and chicken with grilled summer squash
and sweet corn
drizzled in chimichurri come on let's do
it let's do it
one two
a little better than fried chicken i
agree
the skin's still crispy what did you do
to it roasted it
loafer for dessert
his take on strawberry shortcake using
the last strawberries of the season
peach cobbler and strawberry shortcake
were my grandmother's favorites
oh yeah but she would buy those little
supermarket thingies i hated those
this is the real deal this is the real
deal satterfield
credits his grandmother with sparking
his interest in
food it started with fresh biscuits she
made every morning when he was a kid
the same kind he makes today she
was hands down the best home cook
i've ever experienced she would never
let anybody
help her in the kitchen my mom told me
that way later that she said
i don't know what it was about you but
she always let you help
but cooking wasn't his first passion it
wasn't even his second
he studied architecture at georgia tech
before starting the
indy rock band seeley during the
mid-1990s
it was during this time he started
working in restaurants
to make some extra cash so all that life
experience you had in there how do you
think it influenced you
or influences you in the kitchen just
being able to handle curveballs and
adjust
to assess a situation quickly and decide
how do i need to react do i need to
react
or do i need to just keep calm and move
on his biggest adjustment came a few
years
after opening miller union when he was
diagnosed with stage three
testicular cancer i'm grateful that i
i went through it and that i survived
and i
hate hearing about cancer patients that
don't
and it helps you kind of re-prioritize
your life
because you start to really think about
what really matters
and what you can just not care about
anymore
what really matters his partner of 30
years
and his restaurant through which he
hopes to continue making a lasting
impact one diner at a time
if you can connect with local growers in
your area
and find that good seasonal produce
it'll change the way you cook the way
you eat and it'll change the way you
feel
you feel a difference oh i guarantee you
if i eat
vegetables every day i feel great i've
been saying that for years i
i the thing i love about steven was
every moment he's talking about being
grateful gratitude is so
so so much a part of him and so much a
part of his restaurant his
his servers everyone in there is just
happy to be
i love him hearing him talk about
handling curveballs which all restaurant
owners and chefs have to do but on that
i'm grateful for this glass
this is italian red it's uh thank you
for this
thank you free i can never gratitude i
can never remember
the name of it here's a look at the
weather take us for your weekend